hey freddy hello how are you i'm good
i have to tell you i'm having so much
fun watching you in this series you're
so funny in this
i appreciate it that good it's an easy
role they give me
all the the jokes and then i get to go
home it's it's
i'm like kevin pollock and a few good
men i have no responsibilities here
whatsoever
amazing but you take all the glory you
get all the glory but i gotta make sure
i let people know
yeah um were you a fan of the original
punky booster
yeah i'm 44 years old i mean it was on
every day after school
i even watched it a couple years after i
outgrew it because i still liked it
so uh so yeah man i grew up during that
time period
oh man i love that so if you being a fan
of the original is that one of the
reasons why you wanted to join the
cast and join the show or did you just
kind of have an instant chemistry of
soleil
this is a weird story um and a long one
but it's it's a good story
so i was i was done with acting i didn't
like announce it or anything i just took
another job i worked for the wwe
for two years and was was helping their
talent kind of get over and develop
their skills
and when i had kids i quit that and just
became a full-time stay-at-home dad
um so i wasn't interested in it my my
agent
dropped me because i wouldn't read
scripts they were like all right it got
all kind of like sorry dude like i just
i like other stuff
and a mutual friend of soleil and myself
brian austin green who everybody knows
and loves
um he called me up and he said hey you
lazy
eat cussed and uh he goes i know you're
not reading anything
but they really like you they're
remaking punky brewster they really like
you for this role
and uh you should meet so late because
if you meet her you're gonna do it
you're gonna fall in love with her
and i said okay i'll read it we hung up
and i thought is just a job he got
offered
was why i called me otherwise and that
he couldn't do it for whatever reason
because he had another job or something
and so that was it and so instead of
reading it i played call of duty for
about eight or nine hours
straight and then two days later well
priorities
so anyway he calls me two days later and
he cussed me out he's like dude you
didn't even read i told people you're
going to read a script you have to read
i go oh i'm so sorry
he's like it shoots in la and i was like
why are you saying that in the first
place out of reddit right away
i probably wouldn't know but i was just
deflecting so first i read
i read the script and i started laughing
and my wife goes we laughing at
i said you wouldn't believe me if i told
you she goes what are you reading don't
be a jerk
and i get that a lot and uh i go i do
i go uh there it's the punky brewster
pilot and she just stops
she's like what i go what she goes
you're doing it i go i'm not even done
reading the script
she goes i used to do a show locally in
new york called girl talk with soleil
it was only in new york we were like 14.
you're gonna love her she's the son
everything brian said about her she said
about her
so i'm like all right i gotta i gotta
meet this chick so they say hey you're
gonna have lunch with soleil on a
universal lot that's where we shot it
um and you guys will see if you have
chemistry and talk about the character
so i go there and right away she's got
cheeseburgers
and for act for a girl in l.a to eat a
cheeseburger right away i'm like this is
my
this is my girl my wife's the only other
female i ever seen do that in this town
so we're sitting down and we're talking
about this character who they're a
divorced couple
he kind of lived the life that my dad
lived which was drugs and alcohol
and the mother and wife was forced to
divorce him she had to be strong enough
to do that
because the kids weren't safe same way
reason my mom divorced my father because
i wouldn't be safe with him
he was doing drugs and driving a 75
corvette stingray like he just wouldn't
have been good
so his story she's telling me is this
sort of journey of him working his way
back and
re-earning the trust of this family and
how this new character this new punky
whose name is izzy is kind of this
outsider as well
also trying to fit in and they're going
to kind of be
the ones that help each other out so
while she's telling me this great story
and i already know we have a vibe this
this chick comes up and she's dressed in
like the universal studios like uh
usher suit and she's got this sick
haircut
like short like mine but long and crazy
like
not ugly like mine her look sick and
cool i've cut my hair since i was 35 it
looks the way it looks
and it's like she should be in cyberpunk
right and i'm just the whole time
she's talking and i'm just like man i
wish i had this girl's hair like i never
said that i'm tripping out like why
would you want a girl's hair
and that's the only thought on my head
and then she says i hate to say this
but there's going to be a proposal here
in the next five minutes could i ask you
to leave and i'm like
oh your hair is so sick but yeah look
and she's like looking at me like what
yeah but we'll leave we'll leave and so
if you're ever on the universal studios
tour
in la and you're looking at the clock
tower where they actually shot the movie
back to the future
to the left you'll see a new mexico
style adobe staircase that leads to
nowhere
so soleil and i run that way and we
climb up these steps we're in the dark
so we can watch the proposal and still
eat our lunch while it's warm
and the same girl that asked us to leave
is the same girl proposing
she brings her girlfriend out there this
chick gets down on one knee she may the
girl says yes don't worry
and uh she just sat on one knee she
makes her proposal
and the universal studios tram car rolls
up this is pre pandemic
and they start playing the back to the
future theme song and all the tourists
on the [ __ ] start cheering
the couple that just got engaged and i'm
looking at soleil
and she's looking at me and i'm like
look i know y'all heard i was retired
but
i'm if you all want me to do this i'm
gonna do this and i'll give you
everything and she's like we want you to
do this i said i want to do this too
and so it just said yeah and it it was
perfect everything that was that i
didn't like about my sitcom didn't exist
on this sitcom
and everything that i loved about my
show also existed on this sitcom
like i wasn't ready for all the
responsibility they gave me on my show
i was the lead the ep the creator the
writer i had to do everything
and i was spreading myself so thin that
i was crappy at all of it
and uh i just wanted to be the fifth
lead after that show was over and my
agents were like it ain't gonna happen
like they won't even let you read for
that role
forget get offered they won't use this
so i was like cool peace
and this came around and it was just
perfect it literally it was just per i
get to be a stay-at-home dad
get to be with my my kids all the time
never have to leave
soleil is what brian and sarah said she
is the sun
and the rest of the cast and crew we are
planets that revolve around her
and i've said this before but i'll say
it again even when she should take care
of herself
because i hope she hears this she still
won't she'll still
radiate so that you're in your best
position to do your work
which is insane and something that i
couldn't do on my show so i'm always
impressed by that
oh that's amazing and just wrap things
up really quickly is this a show
that you get to watch with your kids is
that something that was kind of you know
an idea that you wanted to do going with
this show
no that that decision had nothing to do
with it but my kids have seen the first
two episodes and we're cracking up and
loved it um so that was kind of a few
because not all our jokes are for kids
it deals with a lot more grown-ups it's
not the normal sitcom we don't solve the
world's problems in 22 minutes
in fact more often than not the family
fails at whatever they're trying to
solve
which was another reason why i loved it
but uh i've been a part of legacy
uh pieces before and i feel like i'm a
good guy
to to be a part of those i felt like i
did scooby justice i felt like i did
uh uh the wars of the stars justice
and i feel like i'll do punky brew star
the justice too man so i
i you know i know where my strengths lie
and i know where they don't um but this
was a good
i mean a character who feels like an
alien
looking at the rest of the world going
man i just really don't fit in
is the story of my friggin life and
that's what this guy's life is so i knew
i could apply that
and and and do that well oh i love that
so much well congrats on the show it's
been such a pleasure talking to you you
play the cool dad really good so
i appreciate you thank you thanks for
giving me the time to talk to you guys
about it